and it overtaking thank you guys so um
this morning we did our whirlwind tour
through various works in information act
and economics so the plan for this hour
is we'll do a little bit of thinking
about what makes privacy an interesting
thing to buy and sell and provide and
quantify its value then we'll do a
different whirlwind tour but in this
case thinking about work that's been
done mostly in the differential privacy
community on various economic ideas
since they're in a relationship to
differential privacy how do you quantify
privacy laws with the role of privacy in
the context of mechanism design issues
like this then I'll do you know sort of
a little bit of the sort of
philosophical less technical effects on
society we're probably Helen should be
doing that part and then I have a few
more sort of vignettes from economics I
want to share towards the end that's the
plan we have an hour go so the first
question is how is data different from
sneakers economies are really good at
thinking about how we should buy sell
price things I what's special about data
and then we'll go on to think about sort
of other ways that we can sort of put
data in in this sort of traditional
economic context so what do I mean when
I say good good is something that's
useful that you might provide or buy or
so it can be physical it could be
service and so let's think about data
versus sneakers so in no particular
order
you got data you can make more copies of
it basically for free if you have
sneakers you still have to pay for the
additional work to make more sneakers if
you have data and you sell it to
somebody
it's really really hard to control its
spread thereafter with sneakers it's a
little more clear what might happen if
you have data it can sometimes be very
difficult to find the right buyer for
that data or to figure out what version
of the data they might want
whereas generally we have pretty
effective markets for selling
traditional goods you know obviously
they are marketed in efficiencies and
issues there but I think we understand
the market space much less for data I do
a gradation with use this is a tricky
one sneakers when you use them they get
older and dirtier and you know at some
point they become less useful data when
you use it it gets older and dirtier and
becomes less useful but in a different
way so as you use data you in some sense
exhaust its ability to support
meaningful statistical conclusions and
there's been nice work in the space and
understanding this I'll talk a little
bit more about this I later but it's an
important factor can to consider when
you are thinking about pricing it or
offering access to it but it's a
different kind of degradation the value
of holding data at least in some context
depends strongly on who else has access
to the same or similar data so if I have
data that lets me you're out the right
way to price for a market segment or
data that lets me figure out exactly you
know what's the product I should be
selling that's really really valuable if
my competitors don't have access to it
and maybe much less so if my competitors
do sneakers
what's the issue the what do I mean by
the curve of marginal values so I its
natural thing about if you had a certain
number of sneakers how much would it be
worth to you to have another pair of
sneakers
and that's what we mean by marginal
value with many but not all goods we see
generally decreasing marginal value so
if you have a one or two sneakers maybe
it's good to have a few more yeah I know
okay I know the pair's I know yeah okay
so so forget the complementarities for
the moment I know I just I don't know
why I like sling sneakers so much but I
do but I but generally you know there's
a point where you got enough sneakers
like you're never gonna wear them yeah
say pairs of sneakers and you're not
just gonna you're not gonna wear more of
them in your lifetime and so the
marginal value kind of goes down I wear
is with data it's a little less clear
what's the shape of the curve so for a
particular thing you might want to do
with data you know I want to use data in
order to distinguish images of cats from
images of dogs
maybe there's a curve that you can draw
that goes something like you know a few
pictures of cats and dogs not so useful
more more more useful and then boom like
my algorithm actually basically starts
working and then more less useful but
not so confident in that curve that I
just drew and it may have some other
bumps and weird things going on but that
was for one application so even suppose
I got that curve right for cats and dogs
now suppose you want to distinguish you
know bicycles from porcupines or do
other things with data there's going to
be another curve and it's going to be
somehow layered on top of this one in
some interesting way so I think the
shape of the curve is not so well
understood for data and I think that's a
really interesting and important
question
the one of the trickiest things about
transacting on data is it's much more
complicated to ask people how much do I
need to pay you for this piece of data
about yourself but it is to ask you how
much do I need to pay you for this pair
of sneakers and the reason is that the
value of the data or the harm you might
incur and giving it out to somebody may
actually depend on the content of the
data so to use the example of being TCS
positive maybe I'm perfectly happy to
tell people that piece of information
for very little compensation if I'm TCS
negative but if I'm TCS positive I'm
worried that I'm going to suffer harm as
a result of people finding this out and
so I want to be compensated more for it
but then sort of traditional mechanisms
for discovering how much I should be
compensated are harder to deal with
because I'm not going to tell you then
you'll find out that I'm TCS positive
just from knowing how much it's worth so
this is something we'll get into as we
continue on and then one of the other
things is that it's pretty clear for the
most part what people are gonna do when
they buy a pair of speakers like they're
gonna wear them or maybe keep them as a
collector's item if people never buy
data it's much much less clear what
they're gonna be able to do with it what
its future value is gonna be how it's
going to be repurposed and generally
when you're selling something that price
is supposed to reflect all of the future
value and uses of that thing that you're
selling but if you can't even comprehend
how it's gonna be used in the future
it's trickier okay this is probably
missing lots of other interesting ways
that data and sneakers are different but
I think this is already basically a list
of open questions because for the most
part we don't fully understand how to
deal with
these differences and certainly as you
start to take combinations of these
interesting aspects of data as a good
we've become less and less confident in
our ability to do something useful there
I think you should take this as an
invitation to think about sort of these
interesting aspects of markets for data
one of the sorry yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so so yeah so there's been some
work on digital goods so some of these
issues are better studied like the
ability to make free copies in the
digital goods space yeah
issues of resale protections against
resale so if I thought yeah there's a
whole literature there I should have
pointed to it but as you start to mix
those concerns with others that are more
specific to the privacy considerations
it gets more murky yeah thanks other
questions here okay so one of the thing
tricky things about talking about
pricing and privacy your selling data is
it's not even immediately clear what is
the thing that you're selling are you
selling a single use of something are
you selling indefinite use of something
resale of it and then what's the
something he's saying a single record an
aggregate statistic a synthetic data set
are you serving selling some sort of
service that you run on sensitive data
are you selling you know the ability to
serve information to a target audience
there are many different things that one
could sell if one had access to
sensitive data and it's not at all clear
which are the right ones to be selling
and then once you've picked some of them
to be selling how they should be priced
because of all those considerations
about how data is an interesting and
difficult thing
to sell and then how the prices should
interact with each other yeah yes so so
yes I I am sorry what is the good
meaning what is the good in the sense of
way what is the thing that you're saying
what are they you know as in the same
sense that sneakers aren't good at that
one might sell so I meant what is what
is the commodity at for sale so I
couldn't hear what you said in the back
okay yes yes yeah what is it what is the
thing that is for sale and so I'm saying
regardless of whether you put the word
data or privacy here there's this a sort
of tricky question of so start with just
with data as the first word in this on
this side yeah so so and then I ended to
this transition to privacy and you want
to slow that slow that transition down
which is great yeah so I thought of this
more as so you can do this slide this
question of what's for sale for data and
I think this slide only gets more sort
of complicated and interesting to think
about when it's sensitive data or a
privacy related service but maybe I
should have separated that into two
steps which is even when we're just
talking about data and we haven't
started to worry about privacy I there
are many functions of data that one
could sell access to and then one that
the data is personal sensitive and we're
thinking about the ability to perhaps
introduce some protections as part of
the thing that we're selling then it
gets even more complicated so perhaps
that should have been two steps yeah
thank you
oh yeah yeah yeah this it this goes on
and on and on
yeah oh yeah you could also speed what's
the discovery yeah that's that's a great
point yeah so you could think about how
do you price that is a good and there's
been some work there and you know for
every comment I realize that there's a
whole literature that we could have
spent a week on but oh well next time so
one thing that's I think interesting
about pricing data is what one might
hope that the price would be doing so if
I'm gonna pay somebody for access to
their data that payment is potentially
doing the work of sort of multiple
things at once this is kind of
interesting so maybe part of what it's
doing is its compensating them that
person for the value of that data
meaning it you know I'm gonna use that
data to go and market something or you
know make some money down the line and
the value that that data contributed
should perhaps be compensated
perhaps I'm also when I'm paying
somebody for their data compensating
them for some loss of privacy or other
rights perhaps I'm also ideally giving
them some insurance against future harms
that might result from the use of the
date and maybe other things as well and
so that's a complicated set of things to
price and put sort of put together all
at once I mean people do price insurance
people do price things that are very
hard to price like the value of a life
people do you know price future economic
utility of a good but it's an
interesting mix of things to be pricing
together and so you know this next slide
is in some ways a little bit of a joke
but I mean sort of the economics 101 way
of thinking about sort of the interim
about prices and supply and demand you
quickly see that it's not quite the
enough of a toolkit and obviously
there's there's much more out there but
well the space that we're dealing with
is so complicated
that you know what happens to demand as
supply changes in the privacy world you
know what are these questions even mean
so this is here not as a lesson but more
as a joke that just to point out that
there are a lot of things we don't
understand with the traditional tools
here so now that it convinced you that
there is a lot of work to be done I do
want to talk a little bit about the work
that has been done and so the question
is you know how do individuals value
privacy or what is the value to
individuals of privacy privacy of data
and various questions sort of in this
space and one sort of Economist's hat
take on this is that well if you want to
know how or whether people value privacy
we could take a revealed preferences
approach so what does that mean so
revealed preferences means if I want to
know you know what you think about
something or how you care about
something I should look at your behavior
and use the behavior to judge you know
what your true preferences were and it's
pretty clear that if you take this to an
extreme reveal preferences suggest that
people don't really care that much about
privacy it's not really worth anything
there's this nice work of art where the
artist made these beautiful cookies
these are actual real cookies that you
can eat with interesting and hip
sounding flavors and she handed them out
to people in exchange for their photos
and addresses and driver's license
numbers and phone numbers and mother's
maiden name social security number you
name it she took people's fingerprints
and people were delighted to hand this
stuff over in exchange for a cookie so
revealed preferences approach says yeah
privates is basically worth the cookie
yes obviously they're problematic things
about that interpretation but it's worth
pausing for a minute to
about what's problematic with the
revealed preferences approach you know
why is this not convincing evidence that
privacy is basically not a value sure
yeah for example yes I mean so there are
many many reasons
but I think it's worth and we don't need
to enumerate them here but it's worth
stopping to think about you know why do
we think it's still worth studying
privacy you know in the presence of this
yes yeah so one of many reasons why I
might still be interested in the status
and so there is a lot of experimental
sort of data based evidence about how
people value privacy and I actually
really don't have a comprehensive view
of this literature but there are many
examples and I can point you tomorrow
and people do go around running these
experiments trying to figure out you
know you know in this particular context
exactly how many pennies will people you
know pay to hide their browser history I
think this particular thing is you know
people were gonna download an app and
there were versions of the app that had
various types of privacy violations that
you had to live with you know how much
you're willing to pay for like the the
more privacy fancy ones so people do
these experiments lots of them and they
do surveys and they ask about attitudes
and this is something that we're gonna
learn much much more about and I at the
workshop that's upcoming this month and
I'm not going to give you in any sense a
a comprehensive view here but I just
like to say that this is
think that's obviously potentially a
really really useful input to our work
as a community and it's also something
that's obviously really really difficult
to do well and to do in a way where
there are conclusions that you can draw
that generalize beyond the specific
setting that was studied and so I don't
want to spend a lot of time here but I
think there there's obviously a role for
doing experimental work in this space if
we're doing survey work in the space and
I think it's also obviously very very
challenging okay so except for maybe a
few minutes towards the end of this
section I'm actually gonna focus now not
on data-driven or experimental evidence
but I'm going to talk now more about
sort of theory and models but back to
the differential privacy world and in
this context there's another survey that
I want to point you to this is a survey
that appeared in siggy calm exchanges by
Aaron Roth and unwashed pie on privacy
and mechanism design which at the time
did a pretty good job of covering all of
the work sort of in the space of
differential privacy and a little bit
outside of differential privacy but not
much plus economic considerations so one
of the first things they do in this
paper is they throw up a definition of
differential privacy it doesn't look
anything like the definition we saw
earlier okay looks a little bit like the
definition we saw earlier this week but
it takes a little bit of parsing to see
why it's equivalent so the the
definition that they they show us is
that a mechanism is differentially
private and for all pairs of neighboring
type vectors and for all utility
functions
the expected utility that you get under
the first type vector worlds and the
expected utility you get in the second
type vector world is very close so this
is sort of a utility theoretic
interpretation of the differential
privacy definition it says that one of
the ways that you can think about
differential privacy is as guaranteeing
that if the mechanisms that are going to
be run on you are differentially private
then your utility is not going to be
terribly degrees
that's a nice interpretation to have
isotype vectors I mean said this this is
now our databases but this is just sort
of putting a database into sort of the
economic terminology so you know in
database land we think about each person
is having information that's an entry in
the database when you speak economics
language you think about everybody has
having a type it's just their
information it's just the thing that
defines who they are in this context
yeah so the next sort of technical
observation about differential privacy
has to do with incentives so for this
you need to have encountered the concept
of dominant-strategy truthfulness and
economics what is it so here's a formal
definition we'll go look at that in a
second but what does it mean
so dominant-strategy truthfulness of a
mechanism or a process that you might
participate in means that well except
for some small you know so if we're
going to talk about a proximate
dominant-strategy treatment truthfulness
except for some you know small epsilon
basically the best thing for you to do
in the face of this mechanism is to
reveal your true data no matter what
everybody else is doing no matter how
crazy they are your model of what we
know what they think about privacy
dominant-strategy truthfulness says the
best thing for you to do is to just
blindly participate with your true
information so this is a concept from
mechanism design that is really really
powerful in the mechanism design world
because if you
try to design mechanisms that are not
don''t strategy truthful it's much much
much harder to think about how people
are going to behave in a response to
them and so it's much much much harder
to reason about sort of the impact and
outcomes of these mechanisms and so it's
sort of by far the dominant paradigm in
mechanism designed to focus on dominant
strategy truthfulness so here we have
this sort of epsilon relaxed version of
this notion and the really striking
proposition and this comes from a paper
of Kunal tawa and Frank McSherry from
2007 is that if a mechanism is epsilon
differentially private then it also is a
proximate dominant strategy truthful so
what this says is that at a very very
formal sense if a mechanism is
differentially private then you are
basically best off by handing it your
true data and this is a pretty
remarkable implication yeah
basically is it the same thing is it you
are on the next slide yes yes yes so
let's get into that approximate and I
end that concern in just a second but
let's let's appreciate the glory of it
for a second before before we get get
upset about the approximate aspect of it
yeah so there's something really quite
striking about this it says that the
interpretation of differential privacy
is if you face a differentially private
mechanism you might as well participate
with your true data because there's
really not any benefit in line yeah I
think a bigger limitation that I don't
might be approximate at all but in this
model utility doesn't depend on the
amount of information that other people
learned about it so it doesn't emit the
possibility that maybe at some point
enough information
you lose your job no no that so that's
actually incorporated here that's the
outcome of the mechanism meaning like it
allocated distribution no no at all
future consequence in the mechanism
that's a really important point actually
to draw out so it actually it
incorporates all of those future
consequences and so then what this is
actually formally saying is that any
future world that you might potentially
you know experience you know the path we
might go down if this mechanism is run
and then you're later denied insurance
versus the path where this mechanism is
run and you know wonderful things happen
to you
all of those possible future worlds the
probability that you end up in some bad
subset of those worlds is almost exactly
the same regardless of whether or not
you provide your true data to the
mechanism and that's a really important
point all this post-processing and we
didn't get to emphasize this because we
didn't really have a you know serious
differential privacy you know tutorial
tutorial at the beginning of this week
is all of these possible future worlds
really basically are unaffected in their
probability by your participation and so
that's really important it's not just
about the outcome of this particular
mechanism it's about everything to come
in the future so that's yeah so that's
something really striking and not
obvious here actually one can actually
use the proposition as a way to oppose
approximately the uncertainty
this yes and that is on the next in this
concert yes and that's the next slide
okay so the good news is a couple of
things Wow we have this fantastic new
tool for mechanism design and it has
really cool properties that we
appreciate so differential privacy has
these composition guarantees that we've
only talked about briefly here and
actually this is something that's
special in the world of mechanism design
the standard strategy proof we're
truthful mechanisms don't necessarily
compose nicely so you can do something
that's truthful and something else
that's truthful in the whole process
together might not actually be truthful
another really cool thing is that we're
doing mechanism design without money so
differential privacy is getting people
to hand over their data without average
actually needing to compensate anybody
and mechanism design without money is
considered to be an interesting dessert
urado now the bad news the approximate
truthfulness and the sort of you know
this is a mockery
so approximate truthfulness is not
truthfulness there is some slack in the
sense that there is potentially some
small benefit that you could get by
lying your about your data or about
withholding your information from the
mechanism yes
and so approximate truthfulness is
probably only convincing to you as a
solution concept if you think that
people have sort of a default tendency
to participate and be truthful or if you
think that there's sort of a cost to
lying there an effort to lying then you
then you can start to justify
approximate truthfulness to yourself as
a concept this one may be even more
disturbing well so I told you that
telling the truth and providing your
data is an approximately dominant
strategy when I swept under the rug is
any report to the mechanism is also an
approximately dominant strategy because
differential privacy you know has this
sort of paradox of what it's telling
people is your data really matters but
your data doesn't really matter
um and in particular no matter what you
head over to the mechanism about the
same things are gonna happen and so that
says okay tell you the truth
approximately domina strategy making up
whatever you want also approximately
dominant strategy and so as call me so
this is a bit of a mockery in some sense
this says it's okay so why would people
participate why why would they give us
anything useful but this is what we have
and so differential privacy sort of with
these ideas in mine has been used as a
tool for mechanism design so the
original paper that sort of highlighted
this truthfulness property approximate
truthfulness property of differential
privacy was the McSherry tawa paper oh
seven and then they applied this as a
tool in the context of digital goods
auctions getting some new results in
that space there's been some interesting
work using differential privacy for
mechanism design in equilibrium
selection mechanisms in this context an
interesting sort of alternative notion
of privacy known as joint differential
privacy has come out where the basic
idea is in many contexts it makes sense
not that the entire output of a
mechanism would be made public but that
each person would receive the part of
the output that's relevant to them so
you find out what path you're supposed
to drive from home to work you don't
find out all the paths that everybody is
supposed to drive because if I found out
your path I know where your home is and
where your work is it doesn't make a lot
of sense so so you can sort of
generalize this idea of sort of
separating the outputs in general at the
notion of differential privacy there but
one of them sort of more striking things
that's happened in this space this is
paper of Kobe and us more dense
contender notes I where they use
differential privacy as a tool to get
not just approximately truthful
mechanisms but exactly truthful
mechanisms and the cool thing that
happens there is they they say basically
most of the time you can go around
running the differential private
mechanism as long as some of the time
you can incorporate a threat that
prevents people from taking advantage of
that approximate truthfulness and so
there's a clever design there and sort
of a slight twist on the usual setting
in order to which a cheat
this okay so stepping aside for for a
little bit from differential privacy as
a tool for mechanism design there's also
been a literature specifically tailored
to this question of eliciting private
data and so this line of work was
started by paper of goshen Roth in 2011
where they show how to use that our
standard mechanism design tools to run
truthful auctions and get accurate
statistics in the settings where
individuals don't have privacy concerns
about their costs for their data so now
we're returning again to that concern
that the amount that you might need to
pay me for my information might be
correlated with the content of that
information so again from TCS plus maybe
you have to pay me a thousand dollars if
I'm TCS negative maybe I don't have to
pay me ten dollars for the data and so
when you set that concern aside you can
basically deploy a standard mechanism
design tools which was a nice
observation and then subsequent work has
observed that actually there are some
impossibility results that emerge for
designing mechanisms with appealing
properties when the costs themselves are
really sensitive information there have
been various responses in the literature
to these negative results so it just
gives sort of a a brief tour of some of
the ideas there so so one approach is a
is sort of to inject additional
assumptions about sort of the structure
and the information that's available
another approach that's been taken in
the literature is to add sort of a
different tool to the toolkit of the
surveyor who's trying to collect the
sensitive data and to allow the survey
or the the following ability I can stand
on a street corner and say $5 for your
data $5 for your data $5 for your data
and you can't avoid having heard the
offer if you can't avoid having heard
the offer
I gotcha and
following sense because if you take the
offer great if you don't take the offer
I learned something about you and I can
take advantage of that okay so that's
another way sort of around I this
impossibility result you can also
introduce additional assumptions and
that are actually fairly benign in order
to get some positive statements here and
there are sort of other ways of
injecting other forms of information
where where you can potentially get some
more positive statements yes in all
these wallets and papers with us play
through in particular with the example
that you just gave I mean that is those
are stylized examples without any
context yes in the context of contextual
integrity it's not clear if anyone would
have evaluation right and have you seen
any of these economies sort of trying to
make that context dependent so the this
literature is not really explicitly
incorporating context normally let me
just say what I mean by context when I
say it in case I'm not using the
language in the same way as everyone
else so so this literature is not
generally thinking about the type of the
data it's not generally thinking about
the relationship between I the the
person who's providing the data and the
surveyor is collecting it um that all
has been abstracted from from the model
and all of these but I think you're
getting to to sort of the next slide in
some sense which is I you know what can
we offer to sort of explicitly provide
some bounds or models about how people's
harms from privacy changes you change
the epsilon in your differentially
private mechanism so anything that's
Universal about that
despite the context where maybe there's
contexts will do rescaling of the harms
but is there some general trend that you
can state you know that as the epsilon
changes the harm
things like that yeah but I think
there's plenty of work to be done in
alternate models in this space so in the
context of sort of how should harm be
measured as if as you change the epsilon
or the epsilon and the Delta if your
differential privacy you guarantee
there's been some some work here so you
see in the Goshen Roth paper sort of an
initial proposal I you know some Lior
function of epsilon in this paper of
Cobie is they point out that maybe you
should think of that linear function of
epsilon is more of an upper bound
because privacy guarantees are very very
worst case case guarantees in the
context of differential privacy so worst
case of the content of the of the
database in worst case over your data
and worst case over the outcomes that
you're concerned about gives some upper
bound on harms in some sense and so
whatever that epsilon is that's giving
you that upper bound it shouldn't
necessarily be that your harms are tied
directly to that epsilon but maybe that
epsilon can be used to upper bound and
so and sort of relatedly if if you take
this epsilon i to two seriously and we
can show that you get two very
problematic predictions as a result so
really at the best absolutely some
function of epsilon might be an upper
bound for harm and there been more
sophisticated proposals in this space
other functions of epileps alone that
you might consider for particular
reasons but I think there's still plenty
that we don't understand about how you
take a guarantee of differential privacy
and interpret the value or the harm that
an individual experiences as a result of
their data passing through this
mechanism
slightly differently different vein of
work but I think also really important
one to point out there's this paper of
Lili McClelland sucio which has a model
for how you might go about pricing
private data in fact maybe this belongs
on a on a later slide what are the
interesting things that comes out of
this paper is sort of the consideration
of arbitrage opportunities so if you
want a price access to many many
different data resources or computations
one of the things you might have to
think about is whether or not this
competition of interest could also have
been accomplished by doing this sequence
of these three other computations and
you know it's odd way to you know have
priced things that people don't need to
think really hard about complex ways to
decompose the computations of interest
in order to strategically pay less in
order to find out what they wanted to
find so there's also been some work in
this line but thinking about sort of the
impacts of privacy concerns on things
you might want to do with data so in a
paper with Rachel Cummings and stretches
to an audience we look at this question
of what if you want to take people
sensitive data and input it into a
computation if you want to do a linear
regression on data that you've elicited
from people what can go wrong and how
can we sort of redesign existing
algorithms and you end up with some
interesting problems because these
private estimators that we previously
hide for the near-great
regression introduced biases that make
this difficult
Rachel also has some interesting work on
introducing privacy guarantees into
prediction markets which relates to sort
of Adams point before that it's really
interesting to think about how we can
aggregate the information that that a
group of people hold and that's
basically the purpose of a prediction
market and what they show is kind of a
nice dichotomy where if you're doing a
one-shot prediction market so there's a
single time where you're going to gather
everybody's information in this
particular way you can introduce privacy
but if you want to do this in a dynamic
way where there's a sort of continual
process that is gathering the
information then introducing privacy
becomes really
problematic because there's this tension
between hiding what you believe and
taking advantage of what you believe in
order to move the market and this is not
the only paper of this flavor by any
means but I wanted to leave this slide
basically blank because I think there's
so much left open in this space is that
there's been relatively very little work
done on actually properly the problem of
the design of a market for data you know
sort of in the context of formal
guarantees of privacy and I think
there's just so much to do in this space
returning to the theme of how hard it is
to get empirical evidence and design
experiments I to learn about people's
privacy preferences I wanted to
highlight two important lessons that
I've taken from economists who run
experiments and they are these the first
is don't lie to your subjects so this is
a an absolute you know hard rule in
economics it is not an absolute hard
rule in other experimental sciences but
I think it's a really important one why
do economists insist that we never lie
to our subjects in the design of an
experiment because if you might lie to
your subjects and they know you might
lie to them how am I supposed to
interpret their behavior they're having
to make guesses about what's really
gonna happen because maybe we lied about
it we can't look inside their heads to
guess what they think we're going to be
doing and then they do something there's
absolutely no way to make sense of it
and this is really really important and
economists insist on this so much that
they won't use a subject pool where
people have lied to the people in that
pool in the past because they want the
subjects to believe the experiment and
to actually do what they would do sort
of in real life in the context of the
experiment that's one really important
lesson I think to take from sort of the
economic perspective another is as
whenever you can prefer a
design that involves incentivize choice
so what do I mean by this it's one thing
to go around and ask people how much do
you value privacy and it's completely a
different thing to see how they behave
when they have to make the choice and it
has real meaningful economic consequence
and economists always prefer to see how
people behave than to see how people say
they would behave and this is I think
another interesting thing to take from
this literature
based on experiment such as this one so
I really want to do squat pounds but
yeah they serve such great snacks so I
go out and I eat all this stuff so
because here I am eating all this pot
great great yeah number one number two I
and this is where I think is really
critical information oh you you threw
things out of the model I think what
you're saying is that you if you throw
things out of the model you can confuse
yourself to no end and I think that
that's the point to take it's not that
incentivize choice is a bad idea
it's that misinterpreting observed
incentivize choice is a bad idea and
it's easy to do that because it's so
hard to get everything into the model
and so when I see that people make bad
privacy choices in the real world the
right interpretation is not people don't
care about privacy the right
interpretation is wow there's a lot of
complicated stuff going on here and what
do we what are we missing from the model
you know did they not have the right
information did they not understand the
choices did they not understand the
implications
have they been conditioned by you know
you know society to make these choices
despite the fact that they're not in
their best interest
fill in a hundred other reasons for why
they might be behaving this way and
people have worked on that but I don't
think it's a to say that you shouldn't
observe incentive eyes choice when you
can it's to say that even incentive
device choice does not answer the whole
question if you're if you're missing you
know pieces of what went into the
decision-making process and I think what
you're saying is also that there are
important things
be gained from surveys that you maybe
can't access by way of incentivize
choice or we don't know how to with
failing to integrate key variables into
it
I think that's bad science I don't think
that that's like I'm not good sure sure
yeah absolutely
I'm and that's one of the things that's
very hard in this space is because there
are so many confounds and it is such a
complex model that I think most of the
experiments give interesting vignettes
from which one cannot actually
scientifically include anything of much
use yeah so has
I mean there many different people who
operate on it but in within economics it
would be I guess the behavioral
economists have there been studies where
instead of trying to sort of rationalize
that now it didn't have prediction
rational choice and some operated with
heuristics that guided things I mean to
incorporate sort of heuristic
decision-making into the model and look
at the predictions from that I know some
things that are vaguely related I know
they know if anything off the top of my
head that's quite fits that model but
that may be that I just don't know the
right literature there and we're very a
sort of low on time there a few more
things that I wanted to say so I'll just
mention briefly despite the fact that it
seems so difficult to do something
useful in a lab setting Rachel and I
along with a couple of econ co-authors
are planning on running an experiment
starting next week actually in a lab and
I just want to say sort of what I think
of this the key idea behind this
experiment is the following I want to do
an experiment about people's privacy
related behaviors you have a few choices
one is you I give them some pretend data
and you say that's your sensitive data
okay go make some choices that doesn't
make a lot of sense why are people going
to behave properly about pretend data
another possibility is you actually
threatened them with exposing real
private data and that doesn't pass IRB
shouldn't
so with what we've tried to do is come
up with another choice which is that
we've created sensitive data in the lab
context by having people play a game
where they essentially have a choice
between something doing something that's
economically good for them or good for
society and when they pick the thing
that's good for them
it's a little bit embarrassing and the
hope is that we'll be able to use this
sensitive data that we create in a lab
context in order to ask and answer some
very very limited questions about
privacy sensitive behaviors I don't have
time to get into the details but come
talk to us and you know preferably
before we start running it give us give
us your thoughts so I'm gonna skip ahead
and talk about a couple other Thanks all
right so but if you want to think about
whether or not you know the work you're
doing the defining new mechanisms to
preserve privacy or new privacy notions
or whatever it is is helping society and
you know improving welfare one of the
things you need to think about is what
are the effects on society it turns out
that's a pretty complicated thing to
think about so we saw from frogs talk
that you know we shouldn't take lightly
the idea that when we introduce a new
mechanism and it requires you know an
extra thousand samples I shouldn't take
lightly the effect on society more
samples can be expensive time-consuming
but it's in the good news is it's
relatively easy to estimate this kind of
cost and this kind of impact on society
may be a harder thing to estimate is
when you introduce new privacy rules or
technologies or hurdles that makes
things harder for a lot of people they
have to implement new technologies or
hire experts and maybe those experts
don't exist or they're expensive it
takes time and money and there's you
know economic evidence that you know
lots of money is wasted in some sense
I'm getting privacy right because maybe
they're not getting it right that's why
I would say wasted and and there's a
concern that all of this time and money
and effort that goes into sort of
following the rules on
have a seat may actually favor the big
players in the sense that they're the
ones who have the big legal departments
to figure out exactly what they need to
do to follow the regulations and there
are the ones who have the big byte
budgets to get the tech in place and
hire the consultants or whatever it is
and the small companies don't have that
and so that's a concern
there's also a slide that I you know and
not qualified to discuss but at some
point you have to think about you know
what are the benefits to society broadly
legally morally philosophically of
providing privacy protections and you
know if you wanted to try to put on an
economist hat in this context you might
think about trying to survey people to
elicit the importance of living in a
privacy just world and what would the
effects be on people's happiness or
other desirable outcomes but this seems
like a really hard thing to quantify in
some sense I kind of hope that privacy
wins even before you include this in the
equation and that this is just a bonus
but it's a question yeah
what employer yes society
he makes the case yeah there's
definitely work in this area Helen's the
person to talk to you in the room about
this yeah but it seems hard to quantify
but it has to it has essentially the
equations somewhere yes you know 1984 is
also a relevant literature there good
there's also this sort of impact it that
privacy protections prevent harms and
these are harms that didn't previously
appear in the equation but maybe they
belong there somewhere so you know
databases that don't exist can't be
hacked trying to protect yourself as an
individual from all of the things that
might happen to you from you know
various future privacy considerations is
costly and has you know various types of
overhead and people are actually paying
real money in today's world for
insurance against privacy harms that's
another cost that you can put sort of
into the equation and then of course
there's a sort of the positive side of
the equation to think about which is I
you know maybe as you introduce privacy
technology is more data will be captured
better data will be captured broader
axis of various segments of society to
data might occur it depends on the
technologies depends on the model but
it's important to think about what are
the impacts going to be you know as you
introduce privacy regulations or
technologies does this increase
competition does it decrease competition
does it increase interoperability across
platform
are these you know things that are going
to contribute to economic growth and
this sort of repeated concern about sort
of complexity and interactions shows up
in a number of places in the literature
but belongs in the equation and then I
promised I was going to come to this so
here it is I there's also this idea that
privacy has this sort of side effect of
inducing stability or robustness of
computations at least differential
privacy and related notions and this has
benefits for statistical validity and so
in some sense the societal benefits of
more privacy prevalent technologies may
be that we get to reuse our data more we
get to share our data more we get better
scientific conclusions we waste fewer
resources as a society by doing things
as a result of false scientific
conclusions we get better government
statistics we allocate our resources
better so getting better statistics
could have potentially huge economic
impact and then there's also sort of the
matter of you know potentially
increasing trust and science and in
government statistics and other
statistical resources I think this is a
really interesting question could we
ever argue that the cost of additional
samples is just completely offset by the
protections and benefits of statistical
validity can we say that actually it was
just worth it just on that level because
I'm low in time going to skip another
example that has Rachel's really fun
slide and say I there are few other at
lessons from economics that I wanted to
point to one is that a lot there are a
lot of counterintuitive effects that are
relevant to us that have been observed
in various places in the literature so
one of them is that when people perceive
that they have greater control of their
information they may actually take
greater risks that leave them more
vulnerable and so we have to be careful
when we design systems that will be used
by real humans the way you present
information to people has some
dan shil effects on behavior even if the
system is behaving the same way and this
is in the context of data and
information there is all sorts of
behavioral biases that various people
have mentioned the various points so to
pull on one that a student of mine
raised at some point there's this
question of when you introduce privacy
technologies and you make people aware
and there's legislation and all of this
you make people think a lot more about
privacy is that a good thing do does
society actually suffer a harm from
having to think more about privacy and
worry more about privacy and be more
aware about privacy is there some sense
in which ignorant is bliss here there's
this really interesting a daycares paper
by Keynesian rooster Cheney which showed
that there were you know there were
daycares in Haifa that we're having
difficulty with parents showing up late
to pick up their kids you know they had
a policy you have to show up by 6:00
p.m. whatever it is parents are showing
up late and so they introduced a fine
you know $1.00 per minute and all of a
sudden people started showing up even
later so the point is when you attach a
price to something it can somehow change
the nature of the thing entirely and I
think that's relevant things like
privacy and data and we have to think
very careful about what we're doing and
how people will respond when we attach a
price to it there's also just another
theme to point to this theme of adverse
selection in compensated surveys so a
lot of people who gather data and track
will probably can say much more about
this that I can worry about paying
people for their data because you get a
completely different population of
people responding and then sometimes
just make stuff up and this is something
that we're gonna have to deal with if
we're getting into a world where we're
compensating people for the use of their
data I don't know why but there's this
one quote in all the papers that I read
barring this talk that somehow just
disturbed me that most of all I mean
like so many things to be disturbed by
but I don't know why evite calm may sell
list if consumer is attending a party in
a given location and somehow I just
thought like this is the world that we
live in you can't go to your your kids
friend's birthday party without this
being sold to somebody what what is this
world but anyway with that a little bit
and take questions thanks guys yes yes a
question
I mean came up in Stanley a few times is
it realistic to quantify public good
benefits to like in the context of like
government statistical agency is right
there the you know the census yeah made
various attempts to make a case people
with sensitive I think we should try I
think it's a very difficult thing to do
but yeah I think I think there should be
concerted effort in that direction I
don't have I'm sorry you were gonna say
something that is the messaging right I
mean they are the campaign's that run
prior to the census oh all about the
public no no no I understand that I
meant more formally rigorously capture
trade-offs between
Oh trade-offs between it yeah I mean you
know like for example you know John
about in they have this paper whether
they are trying to quantify that but you
know as as far as I understood it it
boils down to saying well you know
however you want to quantify that you
should optimize for the like trade-off
between these two yeah which is an
important point but it leaves this
gaping problem of estimating the benefit
yeah I I don't have good answers but I
think it's obviously a very important
question yeah
so it seemed to me like boo stuff you're
talking focused on to classical
economics with rational actors and so on
and then that last slide was the view
yeah yeah and then it all goes to hell
yeah exactly yeah so so basically that's
because there's so much we don't
understand that's already sort of in the
pre you know pre behavioral pre
psychological world but yeah absolutely
that the sort of modern slice of
economic thinking of course belongs here
and it's incredibly relevant I think
we're talking about privacy
considerations so it's it's not that I
neglected it because I think it's not
important it yeah absolutely
even if you say yes absolutely yeah and
I those were on the slide at some point
and they just had to drop off but yeah
I'm completely with you yeah please also
one of these amorphous things that
relates to all these different things
that are all different foods classified
under labor
cautions of your labor
yeah so there's you know of course
incredibly rich literature and
understanding when it comes to labor and
markets for labor and there are a couple
of papers that think about the
implications of that work for data and
you know potential tools that we can use
from sort of the labor perspective but I
think there's plenty more to be done and
and I don't I don't think I can give you
pointers yeah but I I don't think that
we should restrict ourselves to that
interpretation I think we should view it
as a toolkit the I think the data is not
just labor if it is labor at all but
it's very very useful to learn from
everything we understand about labor
the last piece that you mentioned on the
reminding me on the same stuff that I've
been fighting out with away from Ellen I
see how in sort of the common paper on
today over emphasizing privacy we're
putting this in place in places where
it's not necessarily well understood
that it would have that value right it
does remind me or that description that
we have around sensors right I mean if
if they are putting differential privacy
in place for the ten question census the
decennial census where it's information
that is technically out there about you
or pretty easily out there about you
would you think that this could have the
backlash effect because it doesn't seem
like that sensitive and yet there's like
this big machinery going
potentially I hadn't thought about it
particularly in that context but I do
think that we have to be very careful
about introducing a heavy technologies
for a number of reasons I think there
are a number of sorts of resistance that
you get to technologies that are
difficult or a foreign or it's fitting
various words it sort of uncomfortable I
haven't thought about sort of the
salience issue particularly context of
census and I haven't heard it I haven't
really heard people talking about the
salient issue so if you know the
literature is where people are talking
about then in that context of privacy
I'd love to see that